hey francis do you like coffee no mate i
like tea because tea is british this is
british there's kebabs and saint george
he's from indian china kebabs are from
the middle east and some george was
turkish doesn't matter mike you became
british after we smashed the crap out of
that lizard that's what happens when you
look at someone's bird during a night
out
good to know well for those of you who
have a more sophisticated palette than
francis i.e every single one of you if
you enjoy coffee then you have to check
out packed coffee packed coffee or an
award-winning specialist coffee delivery
company they have a hundred percent
specialty grade coffee freshly roasted
to perfection for your order and ground
just moments before it's shipped there
are over 15 different coffees on the
menu at any given time to choose from
including great taste 2020 and 2021
winners pack coffee buys its coffee
direct from farmers and cuts out steps
in the supply chain paying on average 65
above the fair trade base price ensuring
farmers are actually making a profit and
can reinvest in their farms to produce
even more delicious coffee tell your
vegan mates about pack it'll impress
them massively you can plan exactly how
you want your coffee and when it's
delivered to you it's not your typical
subscription that comes on the first of
every month or every wednesday you can
get coffee whatever you want at whatever
frequency you want and you can pause
cancel or change your plan anytime
online make a pack to make better coffee
we'll help you get started with a free
v60 kit worth 11 pounds and 40 free
filters with your first order go to
pactcoffee.com that is p-a-c-t
coffee.com create a flexible coffee
subscription enter the code trigger at
checkout and get a free brewing kit when
you create your subscription plan with
packed coffee and get speciality coffee
through your letterbox don't wait go to
packedcoffee.com
use the code trigger and create your
coffee subscription the code is valid
when you create a packed coffee plan
i mean when i did a talk on prostitution
in the horrors of the global sex trade
at a feminist conference in october
there were a load of blue fringes
outside banging and screaming at the
window shouting [ __ ] are real jobs
what
right you don't do it then mate
[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry i'm
francis foster i'm constantine kissin
and this is a show for you if you want
honest conversations with fascinating
people our fascinating guest for you
today is the author of this brilliant
book feminism for women the real root to
liberation julie binder welcome to
trigonometry thank you very much it's
great to have you on the show it's
wonderful to be here we'll get into all
the feminist stuff in a second but
before we do tell everybody who are you
how are you where you are what has been
your journey through life julie i'm a
journalist and i'm a feminist campaigner
and i actually met feminists when i was
17 years old i was actually looking for
lesbians
there was a bit of an overlap
there was so much of an overlap at the
time
it was let's just say it was indivisible
so looking for feminists when i moved to
leeds from a northeast town called
darlington
obviously it was a big exciting city and
i went into an alternative bookshop
and there with the lesbians you could
tell
short hair ill-fitting jeans
miserable look on their faces that kind
of thing
and
was thrown right in the deep end because
these feminists at the time
were protesting about
peter sutcliffe the yorkshire ripper as
he was known
and he was killing women
around the north north of england
and the police had botched the
investigation so if your viewers don't
know about the case
suckly have killed 13 women actually
many more but they um
remain unsolved
and left seven for dead and he began by
targeting the most vulnerable of women
who he thought no one would care about
so street prostituted women
and of course
the police weren't that interested i
mean they knew
that this was these were serious crimes
but of course these were women who were
worthless
um and who no one was going to care
about which was not the case because we
cared about these women and their
families cared about them
and he then went on to kill women who
weren't in prostitution
some of them
young women and the press decided to
label them innocent victims which meant
that the others of course were not
and some of these women and this is why
it was such a baptism of fire for me
becoming involved at the time that i did
in 1979
is that
some of the women weren't in
prostitution but they were seen
as such
because they had the nerve to go out
drinking on their own
and were enjoying sex with men
so some of them were you know seen as
good time girls well that isn't how
women are supposed to behave and
certainly not
in 1979 in the north of england or
anywhere
so
we were raging against the police for
not actually catching this man because
they were looking in all the wrong
directions
we were raging against them and the
press for telling us to be
safe telling us to stay at home
telling the potential victims that we
couldn't go out at night
when in fact
the home is the most dangerous place for
women and girls
it's where we're most likely to be
killed by
a former or current male partner it's
where we're most likely to be sexually
abused rape had not been raping marriage
had not been criminalized at that time
things were dangerous in the home for
women and we wanted to reclaim the
streets
and so
we did we marched around
leeds and other cities
with banners and placards saying
men off the streets
male violence
no to rape
and one night we did this great um
direct action which is that we mocked up
a load of west yorkshire police flyers
and we put them everywhere
on
lampposts and
doorways saying
men there's a curfew
all men have to be in
off the streets at home by eight o'clock
tonight
and it worked for one night
the streets were free
of men
this might sound anti-men but let me
tell you why it was not
because of course
we shouldn't be responsible for our own
safety
men should not be raping men should not
be killing they shouldn't be making us
feel scared
and what was happening at the time
was while the feminists were going
berserk about this killer
and about the police and the press
response
a lot of men for example leads football
ground ellen road
would be taunting the police
10 nil
11 nil
as the victims stacked up
and they'd be shouting at women on buses
say if they hit on us and we told them
to come [ __ ] off
it would be we hope the ripper gets you
or i might be the ripper
and so
what that whole time in leeds did
was it lifted up the stone
and out crawled all the misogyny
that had been there all along
and that of course the feminist
responded to so that that was my journey
into into feminism and then further down
the line
you know i
for a long time i worked in the grey
economy i was a very good shoplifter you
can't do that anymore
you know the the kind of um technology
got a bit too much for me
so i dropped that bit of check card
frauding and then i met my my partner
who i'm still with and she made me go to
university she said you can't just hang
around doing this kind of thing
don't get a proper job so
i ended up in journalism when i was
about 40 i'm 59 now so
that's my and here you are well look i'm
glad you put that context to the whole
feminist thing because i wanted to ask
you we we've talked about feminism a lot
particularly when we first started
with people who are pro and critical of
it to some extent and i think when you
were talking about the the you know
a mass murderer killing women and
targeting women and the police not doing
anything about it and men taunting like
i think any any sensible person
listening to that would be totally in
support of that that part of it
but i'm a bit younger i didn't go
through that experience i didn't see
that
and so when i encountered feminism as i
matured well not mature but as i became
an adult let's say it was a different
type of feminism at this point and it
was this it felt like that to me at
least
it was
no one was talking about domestic
violence anymore
no one was talking about
this stuff it was all about you know
uh microaggressions in the workplace
someone used the wrong word the air
conditioning isn't quite tailored enough
to women's
whatever you say i'm saying so what is
feminism actually because i think a lot
of young men maybe who are who don't
have the background that you've just
laid out just see it as a sort of a
bunch of people whining about stuff that
doesn't really matter
excuse me yes well the microaggression
thing is a clue isn't it it's micro
so it actually is almost
invisible
so why worry
you know we we walk around
um
being offended constantly
but would never worry about talking
about it or calling anyone to task
because you've just been slightly
offended who cares
but that kind of feminism that you've
described is a very pampered kind of
version
of i mean you see it a lot in the states
they call it lean in feminism so it's oh
i'm only earning a million dollars a
year and he's earning a million and a
quarter
okay i don't actually care about those
issues of course it's indicative of
sexism of course if somebody else is
getting a quarter of a million quid
um a year more than a woman well yeah i
mean it probably possibly is if they're
doing the same job if they're doing
exactly the same job but who actually
cares at that level so i care about the
women at the bottom
and feminism is for all women of course
because all women
um
we're united by one thing only
only only
the fear and reality of male violence
there is nothing else that unites women
i mean bits of our biology but really
um that is it and so of course a woman
however privileged and
however wealthy she is
she can still be
to a lesser extent in many ways
vulnerable to that abuse
because her privilege doesn't protect
her
from that
but
whilst all women benefit from feminism
some women need a damn sight more
and i'm sick of hearing the type of we
used to call them shoulder pads
in the 1990s there's women
that are extremely senior in their work
that talk about issues that can only
matter to them
whilst not caring about other women at
all
so they would no sooner
look at impoverished women
who don't have
the kind of job where they would ever be
given
maternity benefits
than they would
any other kind of oppressed or
minority group they just care about
their own privilege
one of the reasons that i wanted to
bring you on julie was when we were
appearing on gb news together and you
were talking about male violence towards
women particularly at home and that's
something we don't really talk about
anymore
and it's always been in our society and
i think over the last year and a half
due to lockdown it's got significantly
worse because for a lot of women being
able to go to work being able to go and
see people being able to go and meet up
for a coffee
to those types of women that is their
sanctuary that is their escape and all
of a sudden over lockdown that
disappeared and all they had was the
home it's true it's that kind of
isolation that gets even more
extreme so for example the way that um
the way that we look at levels serious
male violence it's actually very
straightforward we look at the morgues
we look at how many deaths there are we
look at how many women are dying at the
hands of men we call it femicide which
means women and girls that die because
they're women and girls and they're
killed by men and it could be sons it's
usually partners or ex-partners
but during lockdown i think a lot of
as you said a lot of the relative
freedom that women had
to escape disappeared
but also it gave some men who are
violent a ready excuse
for their violence so you need we've
heard it over the years
he only hits me when he's drunk well you
know i've been drunk a few times i
haven't lumped anyone
and obviously he's not going into work
and lamping his boss he's choosing to do
it to his wife or his kids
the man called anthony williams who
i think in his 60s
got a bit depressed during lockdown i
mean didn't we all
and he decided to strangle his wife
he said he argued no history of domestic
violence well there possibly wasn't a
history of domestic violence
but there was certainly a loss of
control in that relationship from what
we understand
so he started to throttle his wife in
the bedroom
she saw he meant business so she ran ran
from him
was fumbling with her key in the door to
get out
and he caught up with her so he'd had
that distance between her
running away
and finished the job killed her
and he was successful in his
defense against murder
he was convicted of manslaughter he was
given four years and five months i think
because he said that he was a bit
depressed
there was no need for a psychiatric
report saying that that was clinical
depression the court just accepted his
word
now
contrast that with sally challen i don't
know if you've heard this challenge case
right well
2010 you'll have seen it at the time it
was everywhere
a middle-class white
seemingly very kind you know public
school educated been to finishing school
woman in her 50s
uh bludgeoned her husband to death with
a hammer
totaled him
went to beachy head
with the very very
sincere
desire to throw herself over and kill
herself
she was talked down
[Music]
she was put on trial she was convicted
of his murder
and every single newspaper report ran
the same kind of line
deranged hammer horror killing blah blah
blah
you know there was the usual kind of he
seemed like a nice man there was no
violence
and then
the organization i set up with others in
1990 justice for women
we
look to campaign for and represent women
who've
killed as a response to male violence
and we look
at how they've been treated by the
courts so we just waited we knew we'd
get a letter from sally challen or
somebody related to her
a couple of weeks later it came from her
cousin
can
you represent sally
she was in a terribly abusive
relationship with this man for four
decades
and that's interesting isn't it the kind
of language we use
that somebody's in an abusive
relationship it's not actually an
abusive relationship
he's the abuser she's not
she's not in that relationship he's
doing it to her
and when we uncovered
the
the detail of her life with with richard
challen
it was horrific and it could have been
there for the courts
to see
i mean the first thing and this
definitely is not the most serious but
what would you think
if you went round to a friend's house
a married couple like sally and richard
and you saw on their mantelpiece
a picture of him
sitting
a stride
a sport a red sports car
with either side of him two
bare-breasted dolly birds wearing
nothing but thongs
what would you think to that in the
family home
it's not really right is it
he sent that christmas card to all their
friends and relatives
and put that there for her to look at
every day
he'd annually raped her as punishment
for her being kissed by one of his
friends
wasn't her choice he just happened to
walk in on it
he had belittled her demeaned her
psychologically tortured her
for decades
their sons testified to this her son
david campaigned on her behalf
she was given life for murder we
eventually got that overturned but she'd
served 10 years in prison so if you
compare those two cases
it tells you what
what feminism should be about not the
microaggressions
not the women at the top
but the women who are actually going
through this and have been discriminated
against and blamed when they do
fight back or
or just try to defend themselves
and why is it then that we focus in on
the microaggressions why don't we
talk about these issues which are really
important and which affect women well
you see proper feminists do look there
are hundreds of ways to be a feminist
but most of them are wrong
[Laughter]
every [ __ ] can call themselves a
feminist and they do and they do and the
reason why they do it
i mean women but even some men
is
to then spout the worst kind of
anti-feminism but with authority
so one example ash sarkar
the
navara media right pundit media behind
it
i'm sure that she's a highly intelligent
um woman of talent you know i do not
judge her
for that at all but she's not a feminist
she really isn't a feminist
she's a trans activist
she's a luxury communist or whatever she
calls herself but just because she's a
woman
with a big mouth does not mean she is a
feminist now i'll give you one little
example i mean there are millions i
could use i mean the mad nonsense she
spouts about
how
male sex offenders that identify as um
as women are no danger to really
vulnerable women in prison settings for
example that's just one
so anyway i tweeted something
in response to her
two or three years ago where she was
saying
trans women are no danger at all in the
women's prison estate and i just tweeted
well unless you're a vulnerable woman
who obviously is sexually assaulted by
one of them
and the next thing somebody alerted me
to her tweet which was a thing of beauty
she'd done a search on twitter
not even on google
this is her journalism really kicking in
she'd put the name of a prisoner who'd
taken her own life a case that i knew
about
that i'd campaigned on behalf of
and she'd put my name
and when it didn't come up with a hit of
me tweeting about this woman she said
here we go these transphobes don't care
about women in prison they only
care about being transphobic
and immediately she was piled on
even by my enemies you said oh i think
julie bindle has actually since before
you were born ash set up justice for
women has helped loads of women get out
of prison
and campaigns for prison reform
so i think you've got that wrong
so arrogant didn't correct it didn't
take it down didn't apologize which
actually is quite admirable
but
she will say she's a feminist and she'll
say it in order to
completely
discredit
any of the work i do
or the women that also campaign against
male violence
that's what they do male feminists as
well you know they'll do they're the
same billy bragg
that [ __ ]
[Laughter]
julie you know what you're talking about
is
speaks to so much of the other things
we've discussed on the show where it
seems like everywhere you look now you
have these posers these people who have
they take a pose in public and because
of that they have a large following and
whatever
and there are other people who are doing
actual real work on the ground whose
work in many ways is being undermined
yes by by the posers who who are doing
this and i certainly feel that way
because when you were talking about
sally sally sally challen
i i'm horrified to hear the story let
alone the different treatment judicially
just the story itself is horrific
obviously but to me i don't even see
that and forgive me as a feminist issue
to me that's an issue of injustice of
course it is right
but when you have people running around
talking about how feminism is about the
wrong temperature in the office or
whatever whatever it is
it puts people like me off the whole
thing if i'm honest with you right and
and i think it undermines the cause that
you are advocating for which is clearly
necessary
well the way i look at it because i
don't particularly agree with you
um on one level because of course sexism
is one thing misogyny is another and all
misogynists are sexist but not all
sexists are misogynistic i'm one of
those i think
i think i'm another
so you know caroline credo perez wrote a
great book about the temperature in the
office um
you know i don't mean to
to be facetious it's actually a really
important book
because she tells us things that i
certainly haven't known just about the
way that um firefighters uniforms um are
not
designed for women so therefore when you
have female firefighters their uniforms
don't fit them now that is a small thing
compared to sending a woman to life for
responding to male violence or looking
at rates of femicide in russia which is
you know one of the highest in in the
world
but it still is an indication of sexism
and and of course sexism can lead to
um real discrimination and it can lead
to to worse
than these kind of attitudes i mean wolf
whistling
which julie may i pause you there just
for one second you'll be very welcome to
carry on with your point
this is i want to flesh this out because
we talk about this in other contexts as
well in the issue of race or whatever
where people automatically assume often
that a disparity means discrimination
so
i don't know if this is true and correct
me if i'm wrong but i would imagine the
reason that firefighters uniforms are
designed for men is historically the
overwhelming majority of people
attracted to that profession and for a
period of time allowed to be in a
professional grant were men and
therefore it's just a default setting
it's not because people sat down and
when we hate women or we are against
women or we don't respect women of
course right so is that really sexism or
is it just like a sort of you know this
is the default setting because not many
women have been in this profession and
as it becomes more even if it ever does
that will be taken do you see what i'm
saying i do and the only reason why
women are in the fire service at all is
because feminists campaigned
against the kind of discrimination sure
that that would prevent women from from
being in the fire service i mean to be
honest with you um the kind of feminism
i got involved in very early on as i as
i mentioned at the beginning
is what i see as the life and death
issues and i can't get whipped up about
um equal pay
i care about the women who are on zero
contract towers obviously i don't really
get whipped up about the other stuff
that isn't um as kind of nor do i it's
just you called it sexism and i was just
like is it is it not i think it's sexism
i think it is it is all sexism i think
that
some
effects on women
some of it affects women more than
others um
that there is if there is a default
position which favors men then clearly
that's sexism why
because if you look at
for example billy bragg
who argues he was he decided he had to
explain to women what feminism was last
international women's day i think
and he was saying um timing great is
perfect
and he's double denim
and he was saying look you know feminism
is about equality for all well it isn't
it's about actually liberation for women
equality for all what does that mean
where's the default position
there has to be
something that you are aspiring to be
equal to
and if that's men then that means that
men are the default position which means
that women
are discriminated against in relation to
that
but like i say you know you can you can
measure
the effectiveness of feminism
by
seeing whether or not we've made a
difference in terms of the scale
and prevalence of
rape domestic violence
femicide forced marriage fgm all of the
issues that affect women and girls
because we're women and girls which is
why
the idea that you can just identify into
a gender is so ludicrous
because you know tell that to a girl in
a menstrual hut in nepal
you know tell that to the dead body in
the morgue who's killed because she's
dishonored her family in kurdistan
it's it's nonsense i totally get you and
i know it feels like i'm honing in on a
trivial issue but i'll tell you why i'm
i'm doing it
my concern is
that if we call everything sexism then
nothing is sexy i agree
i absolutely agree with that
and i think that there's a
type of
whinging approach to
that's what i'm getting that right yeah
and i
see the thing is this is my sticking
point i still think it's sexism but i
don't really care but why is it sexism
julie why is it sexism because it is
suggesting that women are of less
importance than men so if you have
something that's kind of set out for
men's convenience for no good reason
um
okay there is a good reason which is the
overwhelming majority of firefighters
are men but why no i'm not disputing
that of course there would have been
some women who wouldn't believe you're
talking about firefighters
are you giving a [ __ ] no
i agree with you julie the reason that
i'm picking up on this is i do think
language is important yes right
so if you're gonna insist on calling it
sexism i'm not disputing that i want you
to explain to me why so i can understand
because right now i don't see it's
chicken and egg isn't it because
obviously um if the majority of any
particular profession or trade yeah amen
then things are set up for them yeah
it's it's like the issue about that
there was one female lou in the house of
commons right because of course there
were no female mps yeah it was probably
there for the cleaner or the caterer or
something and now of course there are
more female mps they want more lose but
honestly i would fall asleep in the
middle of complaining about that i mean
not if i was a female mp but it just
isn't on my radar but it's clearly an
indication of the fact that women were
shot out of much public life they were
they were but is it still sexism today
that uniforms are not made for women in
the same way that they are familiar you
know i think that there's different ways
in which you can put
women off
a particular
trade particular profession
um you know there are there are extreme
ways and there are subtle ways i mean
the ex the extreme way
was the um
the montreal massacre of 1989 in which
14 female engineering students were shot
dead by
who was effectively the first in cell
that we ever heard about resented women
because they had shut him out of the
profession he felt he was entitled to
and that's a really extreme example
of how there's a sense of male
entitlement which means that women will
feel less entitled
yeah all of that i'm behind you
completely 100 percent i just
uh it's part of the conversation that's
ever present in society how whenever
there's a despair like for example
there's an issue for uh black women who
are more likely to die giving birth and
it's automatically assumed that that's
because of racism uh is it we don't know
i mean people have different biological
things there's different things going on
and also of course ethnic minorities
like me and immigrants like me are a
tiny minority of the population so of
course the default setting would be
for the people who've been here for
thousands of years i mean give you an
example when i go to the dentist they
can never knock me out knock the jaw out
properly because i've got an eastern
european jaw structure and it was only
when i met a dentist who understood this
an indian guy as it happens he knew how
to do it he's the first dentist in the
uk who could do that is that's racism
against russians or whatever you just
reminded me of something when i first
met
the woman who was
my partner's mother this was back in
1987.
and that excuse me polish jews and i
have um heritage from russia
um
they uh she said oh
i could tell you had russian heritage
you've got a very square jaw and i
thought thanks very much
thanks ever so much
[Music]
i never had any trouble with the dentist
but
do you see what i'm saying right i
understand and i think that that
happened with kovid also where
one thing was very clear the reason why
so many people of color who were dying
in the beginning
in the who were health workers is
because of the proportion of those who
are domestic minorities that work in
particular jobs at particular levels in
the health service and that tells its
own story but then they started to
become this discourse about how kovid
was almost racist itself by targeting
people of colour and black people
and
obviously you have to look right behind
the story but there was
there was much of that and i think the
guardian ran several pieces that just
didn't stand up
and it was it was very kind it was
histrionic and it was
dripping in the kind of sentiment that
isn't helpful
so yeah i mean i agree with you your
broad point francis take over me i've
asked about 20 questions in a row so
we've covered firefighters you had bad
carbs
yeah we've talked about firefighters
bad firefighter he's the good fighter
okay so
why is it let's go back into this
because this is important why is it that
feminism focuses on the trivial the
banal
the things that i consider to be
unimportant why does it ignore the very
real and the very important issues that
affect women
for instance fgm i've got my own
opinions about that but why is it we
don't talk about this in a full frank
and honest manner
okay well there's two answers to that
question one is that many of us do
so i'm connected to feminist networks
all over the world almost i mean even in
saudi arabia there are active feminists
wow um and you know everywhere in the
world because of course there is no
country in the world that is free from
the the type of issues that we've been
talking about now
rape is in existence in the richest and
most equal countries right through to
the worst to live if you're a woman
so
those of us that campaign to end male
violence
in all our different kind of roles
are very loud and vocal and we have
actually created material change we've
introduced legislation we monitor those
that are supposed to implement the law
um we've raised awareness all of that
but there are also those feminists that
don't really want to get their hands
dirty
so
they might look at the softer issues so
they spend all of their time bleating on
um and i'm going to be so hated for this
about the type of maternity cover in
very elite professions now it goes
without saying that i believe that women
should have maternity cover and
maternity benefits but it's the type of
women for example when i was doing um
some consultancy in
a charity that deals with the
trafficking um and sexual exploitation
of women into the uk
there was one woman in this charity and
oh was she entitled
and she had
three babies in a row
very very
deliberately
within a time frame so that she would
get the maximum
benefits and maternity leave
at a charity that was failing because it
was underfunded
where the women who the charity was
serving were the most disenfranchised
and impoverished imaginable and this
extremely privileged woman milked it she
had her own low stool with her
everywhere she went she was going to the
pilates that was on offer she was taking
time off every single
minute that she could to go to her
appointments with the doula or whatever
and i was so angry about that and yet if
i'd have said
you should put a cap on how many
the traunches of maternity leave these
women should have i would have been seen
as hitler of course because it's never a
mid-range dictator we go straight to
hitler
um
and
and that really winds me up
but it would be extremely
unfair and actually neo-liberal of me to
say
you should put a cap on this because of
course
these benefits are supposed to be for
all women but she didn't need that she
used that charity knowing if she went to
the private sector
she would get far less they'd be far
less generous with her about it
that isn't a feminist thing to do in my
view so i think sometimes it's
complicated but then there's other women
that just
bleat on about
things that you think well this is only
going to benefit you if you solve this
problem this actually doesn't apply to
most women most women aren't in the
types of jobs that you are talking about
wanting to be paid more in or have more
annual leave from or be able to leave
every day at three o'clock to go and
pick up little
millions losca you know from their fee
paying school
so
on on a class
basis you know if we look at the issue
of class
um some of the most elite women will
practice the feminism that is only ever
going to be beneficial to them and their
uh
their um
exactly yeah
hey constantine do you love trigonometry
of course incredible interviews
hilarious live streams hard-hitting
satire plus my handsome jawline whatever
takes away from your hairline but if you
do love trigonometry and you want to
support us there's only one place to do
that and that's on locals yes locals is
a brilliant platform that has been
incredibly supportive to our show and
other problematic creators the great
thing about locals is that it's a
community for people who love
trigonometry that's right it's a place
for you to hang out with like-minded
people share thoughts memes and discuss
the show you can enjoy it for free but
it also gives you the option of
supporting us for as little as seven
dollars a month and if you want to give
more you can we have incredible rewards
for our higher tier supporters as well
we've got everything from mugs monthly
group course and one on two chats with
me and kcat get in join our community by
hitting the link in the description and
the pin comment below see you there guys
what i also find interesting is how
they don't want to this particular brand
of feminist doesn't want to criticize
cultures or practices in other cultures
because they're terrified of being seen
as racist and not and as an ally and you
go well
that to me is racism because you're not
treating everyone equally well it's
worse even than not wanting to speak out
about it they actually endorse some of
these practices
they will twist
something in an orwellian manner that's
quite staggering for example they'll
support the notion that the full face
fail is empowering to women and it's a
[ __ ] you to the west when in fact there
are women in pakistan saudi arabia
bradford that are being coerced into
wearing the full face veil who are
fighting
with other feminists to stop that being
imposed on girls because it is an
infringement of their freedom and it is
an insignia of women's oppression it is
not a symbol of [ __ ] you to the west i
mean it may well be that that's the
sentiment that a particular individual
wearing the full face veil feels but
it's imposed upon a woman
and another example a few years ago
i um i read a tiny little um news item
in the english norwegian newspaper don't
even ask me why i was reading english
speaking norwegian i must have been
really bored that day
and it was that norway is about to
become the first jew jew-free country in
europe
um jews are leaving getting out of
norway the anti-semitism is terrible
and i thought oh i'll go and have a look
at that because i hadn't heard i had
some contacts there and obviously i mean
it was they were focusing on visible
jews so religious jews in the main
house seeds i assume um
so i trots along to norway
and went to the um
the one kosher restaurant which turned
out to be a brick-a-bag store with a
table that you could sit six around that
served
on a wednesday and a monday
kosher chicken whatever
talk to the people there that run the
shop and they told me what the story was
so i i just had it in my head
that were these groups of overt
anti-semites raging around oslo um
saying jews out
and in fact what it was was that the
influx of um
young men
who were coming from middle eastern
countries
who were very very angry about the state
of israel
and about israelis because obviously
they couldn't distinguish between the
policies of the government and
israeli citizens
and further they couldn't distinguish
between israeli jewish citizens and
the jewish diaspora
were
burning israeli flags outside the
embassy and all of that kind of carry on
and the white norwegian woke men
and some women but mainly men
saw their brown brothers
who were clearly the oppressed
palestinian arabs and wanted to support
them that kind of knee-jerk thing of not
even doing their research
and looking at what they were supporting
and they were marching through oslo on a
regular basis
behind
angry men
with signs in arabic saying kill the
jews
now they didn't know because they didn't
read arabic
but actually they could have done a
little bit of research to see what they
were supporting couldn't they
and so what the the jewish community in
oslo and and the rest of norway
were thinking was
okay we don't even have the white
liberals on our side anymore
jews have always had those gentile
liberals
that will be appalled anti-semitism we
don't even have that we're going
and you know of course ironically many
of them
migrated to israel notice what happens
when you have an impression olympics
people can pip you to to the thing right
and that's what's happened
no it's
but again
why is it and
i feel very passionate about this
because we're not talking about the
issues that really impact women we're
just not
and what you have is this surface level
of crap which is being fed to us
and that's what we think feminism is yes
that's what we think it is and it's not
well it's [ __ ] that's why i wrote my
book and that's why i called it feminism
for women because what we've ended up
with is a feminism that benefits men
more than it does women it's all this
pole dancing for exercise sex work is
work trans women are women
all of those issues are really crucial
for feminists to get a proper grip of so
take the issue of prostitution
the discourse around this from
the faux feminists
ash sarkar and all of her mates is sex
work is work
um it's a job
it's a profession i mean when i did a
talk on prostitution in the horrors of
the global sex trade
at a feminist conference in october
there were a load of blue fringes
outside banging and screaming at the
window shouting [ __ ] are real jobs
what
right you
you don't do it then mate
you go and get an unwashed dick into
your mouth and tell me that you'd rather
do that eight times a day than be a
researcher or an academic or a
journalist or whatever why the hell are
you supporting something that has such a
horrendous effect on millions of women
around the world and sets
a context where women's bodies are seen
as orifices to rent and to sell
you know it's an appalling
issue that many sex trade survivors so
women who've actually done prostitution
are now thankfully educating the world
about the realities of this you know i
know loads of the women i've interviewed
hundreds of them and they will say look
when i was in prostitution i used to say
hey i love my work [ __ ] off don't you
dare judge me of course you do i mean
you're coping
in in a horrific situation
but when they get out and if they're
supported enough to be able to do that
from other women
then they'll say
it was hell and no woman should have to
go through this and yeah of course
you've got the odd exception there's
always an exception isn't there the
brock magnante belle de jour type she's
you know funding her phd she prostitutes
from
five star hotels and park park lane
she's
totally atypical she's a tourist right
and yet she speaks with authority just
like those women who aren't feminists
but call themselves feminists i mean
i've known women who say i'm a feminist
i did sex work blow jobs are real jobs
and when you look into what she's
actually been involved in
she was doing
uh her doctoral studies
on phone sex lines so she sat on the end
of a phone sex line for six weeks saying
yes
i've got my tits out
have you got your dick out big boy
hopefully not without intonation julie
because that's not a very good service
is that not how they talk i don't think
so
i mean maybe some people might like a
big boy
i i didn't excited
i have a friend who when i make the
wanking sign she always says i'm not
doing it right and i say how should i
know i've been a lesbian since forever
i see what you're saying they're not
people who've experienced the horrors of
the sex trade in the way that the women
you're trying to protect and stand up
for and defend and advocate for actually
experience so if you get an academic who
who sits on the phone line for a few
months talking that's not the same as
you know being a street prostitute with
all of that or everything
more than that even some of them just
masquerade
some of them lie some of them are i
really do call them tourists in it they
they nip in and out of it and then they
adopt the label so
i was in nevada um where in certain
counties within the state of nevada um
they've had legal brothels forever
um beginning with a gold rush and of
course
dennis hoff
uh the biggest pimp in the world who
thankfully is dead now
who was a real piece of work who ran
these brothels
and uh terrorized the women
and he he was you know seen as just this
great businessman he was normalizing the
sex trade he was making into a great
profession
and he said yes when i asked if i could
go and research his brothels
clearly hadn't googled me
um
i rock up and he's trying to be mr
charming and uh
said you can interview my girls
but he'd primed them to you know he
these women they they
live in these brothels for months on end
um they're not there because there's
another choice waiting for them they're
there because that's the only way they
can make money and they need that money
and many of them are double pimped so
their pimp send them to the legal
brothels where the pimps are businessmen
so it's a horrific system and the women
are no safer
than than under
any other kind of you know criminalized
regime
so
when i was there and saw the reality of
it and the women told me it was like a
one of them said it was a [ __ ]
penitentiary
you can't even leave the brothel unless
you're with an assistant pimp to go into
town
you have your blood test every week
to see if you've got any stis and your
name with the results are put up for all
to see at the reception area you do a
lineup when the john's the punters come
in and you have to stand there not
smiling and wait until they pick you i
mean just like cattle
and in the meantime
there's somebody at the university of
nevada
who's doing her phd on sex work
and in order to research it
she goes into
the brothels
turns a few tricks does a few johns
and interviews the women and then leaves
and completes her phd and says hey
i'm a sex worker
guess what her phd was on
it was on the ability
of women to orgasm during sex work and
she found that if you're over 40 you're
more likely to orgasm during sex work
than if you're under 40. i think that's
the way around
but imagine
doing that
imagine
taking years out of your life
to show
something that is blatantly untrue
by asking a woman do you enjoy
when you have sex with a punter well
guess what they're going to say i love
it
i love my job
and this is now a phd thesis
that will be read by
young students who are being fed this
sex workers work [ __ ]
while books like mine on prostitution
and other critical
are having trigger warnings put on them
in some universities because we say it's
abuse of women it's a human rights
violation it's crazy
this is such a good point judy because
if you remember the case of durham
university which was now correct me if
i'm getting it wrong but they were
advising students how to go into sex
work and how to do it safely that's
right and these are girls of 18 19 20.
now they may be adults but you're not
telling me that someone of 1819 is aware
of the full ramifications of this type
of work particularly in the internet age
and if that was my daughter i would
personally drive oh i can't drive i'd
get the train myself
in order to strangle them
because to me that is abuse why is it we
have just normalized this and all of a
sudden we're like hey anything 19 year
old girl come in yeah exactly mainly
because of academics but they are many
of them take funding directly from the
sex trade to do this research and of
course what the the pimps and the you
know the
profiteers
want is blanket decriminalization and
total normalization
because of course they do i mean this is
just about profit it's about money for
them
so for durham university to say here's
how you become
safe in sex work it's like telling some
bloke that he should go and work in an
asbestos-ridden factory and here's how
to wear proper protective gear
it's not safe it's not safe under
legalization it's not safe under any
regime except for where you're actually
throwing the kitchen sink at the women
to help them get out and the idea that
universities
are encouraging this
when for many women working class women
the women that could well have ended up
being sexually exploited
see education is a way out of that and
something to give them better
opportunities it's disgraceful and they
don't want to do it so the academics in
their ivory towers why don't they just
set up a brothel
why are they on an academic salary
i mean it's an interesting point julian
it's a point again which speaks to so
many other of the other things we've
been discussing on the show for years
now which is
the gigantic disconnect between the
media and the political class and the
academic
institutions and actual people in the
actual real world and you know you saw
it with brexit
and as everyone knows francis and i both
voted remain and there was all this
stuff about you know we'll be better off
by one percent if we stay in and all and
and you're just going you people don't
understand
what actual people in the real world
they're experiencing
and that's why i think there's a lot of
skepticism now in with about things to
do with covert because you've under i
wrote a massive long thread on twitter
about it
you've undermined trust in all of these
institutions the academia the media the
politicians and now you're telling
people to do stuff well a lot of them
are going well you lied about everything
else
yeah i mean it's a real worry um
you know i
i think
once we know that our politicians can
lie to us and not even lie about lying
to us then that's it you know we're done
for
and it used to be that it was a huge
scandal when politicians were found out
lying now it's just expected
and it's becoming more and more trumpian
and that that's the thing that really
worries me and you know i feel
politically homeless uh you know i
couldn't if there were if there was a
general election tomorrow i'd i'd i
think i'd have to force myself to vote
labor but why
i mean it's it's a disgrace of a party
it doesn't represent working-class
people anymore it used to and it it does
not
in any way and that's why of course so
many traditional working-class people
like all of my family in my community
where i grew up
some of them moved to um
to ukip some of them some of them even
moved tory for god's sake i mean that
was unthinkable when i was growing up
you would never have a tory anywhere
near
where we we worked and lived and played
and julie you say the labour party used
to represent working-class people what
period are you talking about because i
would imagine there were a lot of people
who felt that even tony blair coming in
was already starting to undermine that
but with tony blair the argument was
well at least he's going to get you
elected he's going to get you in power
he's going to put money into public
services which to be fair term he did i
have a lot of issues with tony blair a
lot but on that stuff he did deliver for
ordinary people there's no question
about it but what you've got now
is a party that has simultaneously
disconnected from
working-class people and absolutely
useless when it comes to getting elected
and
really bad
for women right really bad
blair
really gave a damn about the north east
he was
the first leader i think that really
focused on
issues that that were usually just
stepped over
you know scotland has always been
favored
over the northeast of england and yet we
hear the voices from scotland
way louder than we do the voices from
the northeast of england
um
and my community is is much worse off
but
it's a good question when well i mean
blair did bring in so many policies that
helped
impoverished and working-class people
there's no question about that and i
also have issues with him but i think
that you know to dismiss somebody's
entire
body of work
is
tragic
and the iraq war is no small thing we we
absolutely know that
but to throw every single thing out is
indicative
of the whole council culture context
where you have someone who has done
brilliant work for decades
but they're transphobic
um which is usually [ __ ] anyway
and therefore nothing that they have
ever done
in the past or to date
can ever be considered worthy
how the hell did we get to this
i mean you know
we we see the way that
some people have contributed hugely
to culture
um
and
they have done no small bad thing
you know often they have committed
terrible acts of violence towards women
children whatever
and
up until about a decade ago
even the hard-line feminists like me
wouldn't dismiss absolutely everything
that that person had done
because they had also committed a
heinous act
or had a particularly
hideous view
so now we strive for perfection
but who are the people demanding this
what do they do they sit on twitter
they sit behind their keyboards they
contribute nothing material to the world
a lot of them
that is such a beautiful point and you
know what uh francis said to me oh let's
get julie on she's fierce and you'll
probably disagree with her a lot and
look there'll be stuff that we just but
i i'm really appreciating i can tell
that you're a person who thinks for
themselves
and who who's authentic about what they
say and i i love that i really enjoy
that conversation and this is such an
important point because we were having
this argument just the other day you
know
there are people who are who've
committed terrible acts against children
particularly but created great music or
great art and whatever
i don't know i don't know what to do
with that i i i don't i i don't have an
answer what do we do with those people
how do we do we cancel their music do we
stop listening to the
music do we you know what do we do as a
society with people who've done
something terrible yeah i mean on a kind
of
i suppose less extreme
level yeah the music of snoop dogg
so i love rapping hip hop me too and i
love snoop dogg and i went to
glastonbury to interview him and went to
his concert a few years ago
and
there were some feminists that were
horrified how can you be a feminist well
sorry godfather two is my favorite film
what do you mean how can you be a
feminist
and like the music of snoop dogg or like
a particular film
it's called entertainment and it's
called
being selective
with what you like and don't like so
i don't actually like snoop dogg's
lyrics when he calls women hoes and
[ __ ]
kel's surprise
but
i kind of can manage to navigate what i
do like without saying i actually like
snoop dogg's music which means i like
him calling women hoes and [ __ ]
i mean we do this all the time
and it used to be perfectly acceptable
to have friends with whom you profoundly
disagree do you remember those yes
yes i like some tories i mean actually
one of the um
slog t-shirt slogans that really winds
me up is never kissed a tory well i
don't think i've ever kissed a tory
either but there are some that i
actually quite like
as individuals as human beings whose
company
i enjoy
and when did that stop
being all right
because isn't that how we get to know
whether or not we've shifted our
opinions on things
and i suppose some people are just so
arrogant that they think i've formed all
of my opinions they're all correct and
that's it now they're stagnant and
they'll never change
i mean i think i'd probably shoot myself
if i ever became a tory but
you know i
i understand i learn from
from people i hope
for example when i met um my my
partner's father
ernest wistricht he got written into
europe with george soros in the 70s he
he ran the um
the referendum
and he taught me so much about europe
because i used to go mad when i started
going to
european parliament and saw the fat cats
and saw some of the things that we
really would have wanted to reform if
we'd remained
um i used to go absolutely berserk and
he would explain things to me about how
things worked and he was head of the
european movement for a long time
and
of course
i was pro-european
but what i didn't understand until we
had these conversations
was how he became such an ardent
european and it was so we didn't ever
have another
inter-european war
and that's the bit that's missing
from a lot of
the kind of pro-remain arguments
you know ernest you know his family
somebody said his family perished in the
holocaust
he got out in time um his mother was
there he was in poland throughout the
war in hiding
and
just by listening to him talk about
these things
i really shifted my position
on some of that
and
we would also have conversations he was
he was a liberal
and he defended pornography and in fact
my mother-in-law enid was rich she was
the um she was under ken livingstone's
um
glc
she opposed mary whitehouse
the two were loggerheads over censorship
so she would just pass all the films
you know that one's fine that's fine
that's like there's all kinds of like
rabid bunking and
sadism going on and nina just say no as
a good liberal i want you know
but actually we we would talk about that
as you know two
feminists anti the porn industry
and these two
ardent liberals and we shifted their
positions also
so we'd have these great conversations
across big issues
and we would change each other's minds
you're going to make me cry julie
you are i miss those days but that's
what we try and do on this show you know
and i i like i say i'm i've really
enjoyed the conversation because i crave
this i miss this
and the fact that society no longer
allows us to do this in public
to me that's a crime i agree that's
criminal that we can't have because
you've come in here and i i'm someone
who makes jokes about feminism all the
time you've actually shown me there are
bits of feminism that are absolutely
[ __ ] essential
absolutely essential and they need to be
addressed and you know we've had we have
a close friend of ours who who's a woman
very very high achieving woman single
mom of you know doing great and she's
someone who's not i don't think would
say that she's a feminist when she was
talking about domestic violence
you know you sit and listen and you go
okay this is a bit that i was missing
you know
that's what we need more of we need
conversation i agree
yeah and actually the biggest myth about
feminism and feminists like me
is that we're man haters we are the most
optimistic political movement on the
planet
because we don't actually think that
boys are born programmed to hate
or hurt or abuse women
not at all and we know
that those men even those that are
entrenched in misogynistic
points of view and they are in the
minority
that we can all change we can all look
back and think whoa i used to be x y and
z
and actually that was really unhealthy
and i feel so much better now that i've
actually thought about it a bit more all
of us so
so actually feminists are the opposite
of man hating we hate
the the abuse that is is condoned um
and justified by some men as well as
those that carry out the abuse but we
absolutely
celebrate the fact that we can also work
with men
uh to challenge
these
you know this state of play
so we are
we're very lovely actually as problems
we're so nice
so
the question that i want to ask and the
last one is what do we do about an
industry like prostitution what do we do
about it julie because the reality is we
have male libido male libido is what it
is
it's the oldest profession in the world
quote unquote what do we do about it
yeah
this is this is where
we always get he's gonna get
well what do we want it's just a crucial
question yeah and the reason i wrote my
last previous book um was because this
question was put to me all the time
by people who would say look it's the
oldest profession and i would say well
it's the oldest depression you know
midwifery and agriculture are probably
the oldest professor it's not a
profession
and actually male libido i mean clearly
you know as a hard-line lesbian i know
very little about that what i do know is
that if men want more sex than do women
which which is i think a myth and i
think that's part of a social construct
about women being blamed and punished
for wanting sex i think women are
reluctant to admit that they want sex
and men it's a great badge of honor
isn't it that you're a red-blooded man
who wants loads of sex
permanent stiffy all the rest of it but
that if men want more sex than do women
well it's what your right hand's for
mate i mean you don't want to be having
sex with women you don't want to have
sex with you it's called rape
you know and and although we don't see
prostitution sex as rape because there's
the cash is supposedly the consent
what are men doing having sex with a
woman who doesn't want it with him you
know it's it's really it's not good
and and the cash is the coercion
if the cash didn't didn't play a part in
it she wouldn't want sex with men you
know she
the clue is that it's not a real date
so what do we do about it well
the smoke screen the the woman
who is the happy hooker is always put up
as the smoke screen for actually men's
privilege and men's entitlement
we shouldn't be saying this woman wants
to be in sex work this woman has the
right to choose how can you as a
feminist tell a woman what not to do
with her body which is why i don't what
i say is men don't have a right to pay
for sex so what we do about the sex
trade is
we recognize that the vast vast majority
of women want out so we think about
alternatives and we think about exit
strategies because they'll come running
to them they every single time that any
exit strategies are suggested to women
rather than a cup of tea and a condom
they take up
the offer and we say to men okay it's a
bit like smoking in public buildings
guys right
so
it's harmful to other people so what
you're doing it's not a victimless crime
and we're going to have a big public
awareness campaign around why
prostitution is harmful
and why you don't need it your dick
won't fall off if you don't get your
rocks off when you want it with whom
exactly how you want it
so therefore we criminalize the paying
for sex but we don't put men in the
stocks or in prison or
um
it's a kind of deterrent and you know
you're going to get fined and you're
going to it's going to be down on your
record
and
we help the women get out and we change
attitudes we change hearts and minds and
they've done this in several countries
sweden was the first one in 1999 to
criminalize the demand and that would
apply to women also but it's men it's
women don't pay for sex as the general
rule they just don't
and of course most prostituted people
are women
but it applies you know that the support
and exiting strategies are there for any
person in prostitution
and
yes it's been rolled out in several
countries
it's called the abolitionist model
because it's there's a kind of a view
the end game is
an end to prostitution and when people
say
you can't end prostitution well why
it's not there's nothing natural or
innate about it
you you wouldn't say that about child
poverty or or racism you
you know it's a hard ask but you would
never say we'll never get rid of child
abuse i'll tell you what we'll do
you know we'll just make it a bit safer
for them when they're being abused you
know we we see
our role um as eradicating a social ill
so i think we need to have a
conversation about
why do we assume men need
sex
why do we assume men have a right to sex
there are many
men who can't get a real date
and
i'm sorry that they can't get a real
date
but that happens to women as well
and women don't actually order
you know sex on wheels to come around to
her house
so she can get her rocks off with
someone who doesn't want to get their
rocks off with her
it's a male thing it's a man thing
it's true it is um
i was going to go to our last question
but
if i let me tell you how to do feminism
correctly judy no
the only thing i would personally just
say is that
i i'm someone who actually agrees with a
lot of what you just said i would never
want to have sex with someone who
doesn't want to have sex with me i would
never i'd never have and never would use
a sex worker not because it's deeply
immoral in this just because it doesn't
accord with what i think about that
issue
um
but i also think your message would
reach me better i'm not talking
necessarily about other people if it was
if you were talking about rather than
talking about men you were talking about
the specific people
who use that do you see what i'm saying
yes that's that's all i i would say no i
think that's absolutely right most men
don't pay for sex and this is something
that i always always make the point
about that in this country the latest
figures most recent figures are around
11 of men have at some time paid for sex
so many of them will not be entrenched
buyers and i've interviewed a lot of men
who pay for sex and some of them are
deeply ambivalent about it
and actually
don't really enjoy it that much and some
are absolute hardcore this is my right
i want to do things to her that a woman
i wasn't paying would say no to which is
really
hideous
but most men don't
and then you've got countries like spain
where they have a much higher
um rate of sex buyers so something like
38 40
because they've legalized and normalized
the sex trade to the point of where it's
seen as just going out and buying a
burger
germany where it's legalized you've got
um
60 euros um a 60 euro deal
at certain times of the day in the mega
brothels
which is
a beer a burger and bang all you can
all night
and you know there are there are
horrendous things that go on in those
brothels there are men that ask for
heavily pregnant women there are gang
bangs
all seen as perfectly fine
because cash is changing hands and so we
need to look at the culture of
prostitution and dispel the myths and
and really kind of unpick all of the
mythology around it the fact that it's a
woman's right
almost like we're talking about bodily
autonomy
this is not about her right or her lack
of right
she doesn't want to be there
and you're right it's
i agree with you it has to be addressing
the sex buyer
and not the male population in general
because you get the rest of the male
population on board with you i just
think more effectively if that was the
way the conversation which we need we
need to do and in fact you know i've met
through this work i've met
many men in particular actually men who
are disabled who are also held up as a
smoke screen so but what about men who
are disabled who've right one example i
was given a few years ago was a
returning uh
veteran from the iraq war
he's had his legs blown off he's
almost a paraplegic interestingly he can
still get it up
so he wants
sex and it's as though he's entitled
he's not but also there are many
disabled men
who actually do have a real date who do
are in relationships and some who are
not
but it's deeply offensive to disabled
people
to say that you should be able to buy
sex because it's clear no one wants to
shag you
so you need to pay for it
so we need to to unpick all of the
mythology around it and one is poor
disabled men who can't get a real date
that's used a lot i've heard that a lot
all right well i think we've probably
covered everything today we've offended
everybody that's fantastic julie it's
been a genuine pleasure a genuine
pleasure thank you so much for coming on
we have one final question for you which
is always the same what is the one
before we do our locals questions which
is what is the one thing we're not
talking about as a society that would
really should be
rape
we think we talk about it a lot
because it's always in the news in one
guys or another but we don't talk about
what it actually is
we don't talk about it as an expression
of hatred and control
and sexual entitlement
and that's
the conversation that we're missing we
see it as sex we see it as force and
it's actually about neither of those
things and why is that important julia
i'm asking because i i don't know much
about it why is that distinction so
important because it's so commonplace
that if we think about it as being
committed by monsters who literally
force a woman by holding a gun to her
head we only look at the most extreme
cases that are very rare
and we don't look at the rape culture in
which we live it's very commonplace ask
pretty much any married woman of a
particular age
and ask if she has
if she's had sex with her partner her
male partner recently that she didn't
want to have
you don't call it rape to her or you'll
get a very different answer and she will
tell you yes she's been coerced into sex
and that's pretty much every woman under
the age of 30 that i speak to
it's much more prevalent than we think
and it really isn't
the the masked marauder carrying a knife
breaking into women's houses that
happens but it's rare
judy it's been an absolute pleasure
thank you so much for coming on the show
if people want to find you where's the
best place to do that
twitter where i'm always hanging out and
getting into arguments
and of course uh get the book uh
feminism for women the real liberation
julie bindle thank you so much we are
going to do a couple of questions for
our supporters only which you can access
by joining our locals but in the
meantime thank you so much for watching
this brilliant interview uh we'll see
you very soon with another one or all
show all of them go out at 7pm uk time
and for those of you who like your
trigonometry on the go it's also
available as a podcast take care and see
you soon guys
we hope you've enjoyed this incredible
interview remember to subscribe and hit
the bell button so that you never miss
another fantastic episode and if you
believe that the work we do here at
trigonometry is important support us by
joining our local community using the
link below